some people have actually told me the  world's greatest archer are you one of  those people the banter between clint  and kate is all natural as the two  actors had great chemistry on set their  chemistry was so on the scene where  clint and cade hold an arrow together  was originally a simple dialogue scene  with the gesture improvised on the spot  you made it look so easy and cool what  do you get when you mix florence pew  hailey steinfeld in a bottle of hot  sauce great improvised moments  do you have one fork i'm one person  that's so weird  are you done  yeah i go  sure can i can put hot sauce on it turns  out jeremy renner is a big kid on set as  it was his idea to have clint swimming  through the ball pit that's wonderful